- She, like,
strolls onto the bed,
and she takes a shit,
like she's dropping the mic.
She's like,
"My job's done here.
Try to lose your virginity now,
after that."
[dark electronic music]
[heartbeat pulsing]
♪
[slurping]
[cheers and applause]
- Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening".
I'm Ari Shaffir, and tonight
the topic is "bloodline."
[cheers and applause]
Please, give a warm
round of applause.
Miss Hannah Friedman,
everybody.
Let her hear it!
[cheers and applause]
- So my sister's the
coolest person in my whole town.
And let me explain a little bit
about my sister--
I got to go back.
My mom used to work
training monkeys
as aids
for quadriplegics.
[laughter]
So--
So like Seeing Eye dogs,
they help the blind.
They tried to get these monkeys
to help quadriplegics.
Turns out monkeys are
very unhelpful.
They're--they really don't
want to be helpful,
they're not interested
in being helpful.
Um, and so like,
the quadriplegics would have
a little straw to
blow into to release a treat
if the monkey did
a good behavior,
like, uh, you know, give them--
like, turn a page in a book,
or something.
But the monkeys realized
that if you just
take the quadriplegic's head
and jam it down
onto the straw,
then they'll breathe out,
releasing all the treats.
Why work, with--
if that's what you can do.
So, um, so my mom realized
this wasn't a great program,
sort of at the same time
that her favorite monkey,
her test monkey, um,
was on the brink of death.
She was gonna die.
And she was in this horrible
cage in a laboratory.
And my mom was like,
"I want to give her
"a peaceful place to die.
"I want to have a funeral for
her like Princess Diana.
"I just want it
to be very dignified,
I'm leaving this program."
So my mom, what she did is she
signed the monkey out as dead,
she took her home,
and she fed the monkey
bagels and lox.
And then the monkey proceeded
to live through the weekend,
and then for 30 years.
For 30 more years
in the house
with my family.
So everyone says,
"Oh, my gosh,
"you have a monkey as a sister,
that's my dream!
That's so cool!"
It's not cool,
and it's not a dream
'cause she was a huge bitch.
She's very abusive
and mean.
And, like, I would tell,
you know, my--my--my, uh,
second-grade teacher,
"Oh,"
like, "my collage
got ripped up by my monkey."
And she'd think
that I was, um,
uh, disturbed,
and I had to go to
the psychologist--
the school psychologist
'cause my mom didn't bother
to bring a monkey in or explain.
Or the monkey,
she's really diabolical.
So she would, like,
take my favorite
holographic, magic 8-ball Pog
and, like,
tear off the top of it.
She knew,
and she would, like,
pee on my dolls.
Or she would, like--she
had these like long, monkey,
Crypt Keeper fingers,
and she would,
uh, unscrew the peanut butter,
which is my favorite,
and she'd, like,
run her fingers through it.
And just, like, look at me
like, "What are you gonna do?"
Nothing, 'cause
she was my mom's favorite.
Um, and actually, do you guys--
you--do--do you want to see her?
You want to see
a picture of her?
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
Okay, so I have my little helper
here, oh, thank you very much.
So here's, uh,
here she is
in a, in a terry cloth, uh,
beach robe.
Nice.
There she is, Amelia.
This is Amelia, she has--
she's eating challah
with an eye infection.
Ooh.
Nice, on the kitchen table.
Very sanitary.
I'd come home like,
"Mom, I got an A!"
And then everyone would be like,
"Oh, my God, look,
Amelia's eating spaghetti
with her feet, oh!"
You can't beat that.
And here, this is what I showed
to my therapist
very recently, um.
I don't know if you can see,
so--so--
I'm in a--some sort of crate?
Um...
And she gets to be drinking
my bottle, so that's great.
And she's having freedom,
so that's all nice.
Thanks, Ameli--um.
So things got even worse
when I went through puberty.
Dogs just want--to be--
you're the master.
And they want you
to like them,
but monkeys have this
very rigid hierarchical system.
And when she sensed that I was,
like, becoming a woman,
she would, uh,
she would attack me
and she would, like,
lurk behind a darkened doorway
for--she was like a Gremlin.
It was like
living with a horrible goblin.
She would lurk for me
to come by the doorway,
and then she'd like
jump out and, like,
bite my Achilles tendon
and she'd laugh,
and monkeys laugh like this,
they're like--
[breathy laughter]
Which is way creepier
with no sound.
Or she would, like,
wait for me to be
carrying something
really hot or heavy, like pasta,
and she would attack me.
Or the worst is
I would be on the toilet--
you just want some solitude,
you want to be by yourself,
have some relaxing time.
Um, and she would
come and attack me.
Oh, she was also
very jealous of my boyfriend.
Um, she was
really flirtatious,
and this is how--
here, you help me out.
I'll--I'll do monkey flirt
with you.
Ready?
Imagine I'm drooling a lot.
And then she would--
she would go like this.
She'd like rub her tummy
at him,
and he'd be like,
"That's so cute."
And I would say,
"No, you don't understand!
She--she ripped up
all my homework."
Um, and she--
she particularly
didn't like my laugh, um.
You guys are smiling,
it's awesome.
Laughing, great.
Don't do that to a monkey
'cause it's--
you're baring your teeth,
that's a sign of aggression.
So anytime I laughed,
she'd be like,
"Oh, you want to go?"
Like, "I'm down!"
Like, "Bring it!"
So I was so in love
with my boyfriend.
Uh, and we were ready,
when I was 16,
to "do it,"
and I was so excited.
And I planned it,
um, 'cause as the ladies
in the audience know, like,
ambience is very important
when you're gonna
lose the V card.
So I got princess
mosquito netting,
and I got votive candles,
candles, um...
Always in style.
And I laid them all around,
and it was so perfect.
And we waited for my parents
to be out of the house,
across the street
at a holiday party.
Oh, my gosh.
And so we were making out
and fooling around
and it was like getting,
like, hot,
and he took off his shirt
and like--
[exhales]
It was so steamy.
And I was giggling 'cause
I was a little bit nervous.
And all of a sudden, like,
we--we're getting naked
and then we hear--bam!
Bam!
And the door busts down,
like the Gestapo
has come to town.
And we look
and it's Amelia,
and she's heard the laughing,
and she's like,
"Oh, it's on," like.
"Yeah.
Yeah!"
[stammers] She thinks that
I've been sitting in the bedroom
just like, "You fucking bitch,"
and like, "I'm gonna..."
She's super pissed.
And she's jealous 'cause
I'm with my boyfriend.
And so she runs onto the bed,
and she's like,
"Ra, ra, ra, ra, rah."
And my boyfriend covered up
his junk with a pillow.
And I'm like trying to
shoo her away,
but she's really fast.
So she runs
and she gets tangled up
in the mosquito netting,
and she's like re--
she's a ball of rage
in a net.
And I think, like,
"Okay, at least now,
she's like contained."
But she pull--
she's so strong she pulls down
the mosquito netting,
and now she's, like,
running with a big net
behind her.
And what I now know
about mosquito netting
is that it's quite flammable.
So she pulls it through this,
like, row of votive candles.
And it catches on fire.
And now she's trailing fire
like a comet,
and I'm like, "Oh, my God,
I'm gonna, like,
burn my sister to death,"
and I'm naked
and my boyfriend's screaming.
So we, like, put it out
with pillows.
And there's, like, smoke.
And my parents have heard
all this commotion.
And they show up
at the door.
And my boyfriend
is just so stoic--
he's just like,
"Mr. Friedman,"
like,
just really trying
to recover it,
um, and Amelia has, uh,
de-tangled from the net.
And she goes onto the bed,
she like strolls onto the bed,
and she takes a shit,
like she's dropping the mic,
She's like,
"My job's done here.
Try to lose your virginity now,
after that."
She strolls out.
And, um, and that was that.
Eventually I did lose my
virginity in a horrible car.
I had, like, seat buckles
pressed--impressions in my ass,
very romantic.
Um, but I went home recently.
Amelia--Amelia passed away
after 30--30 years with us.
She had lived a really
wonderful life.
And my mom gave her the
dignified Princess Diana funeral
that she always wanted.
It was an open-casket
ceremony.
It was super creepy.
The whole town came.
She was a smoking jacket.
Never in real life,
but in the funeral, yes.
I don't know why.
Um, and since then,
I've gone home
and I've been, like,
on the toilet, thinking, like,
"Oh, my gosh!
It's--oh, no."
And then I realize she's not
gonna be there.
And I walk into a darkened room
and I realize she's not there.
And I thought I'd be relieved,
but it's--
it's kind of sad, um,
and I think about
what I do now,
like, I get to tell, like,
cool stories to people like you,
and I think about the people
who said, "Oh, it's so cool
you had a monkey
as a sister."
And I think, "Maybe they
were right, and I was wrong."
[cheers and applause]
[dark electronic music]
♪